hey Luke here at the altar boys YouTube
channel today I am going to be restoring
this antique cast-iron teakettle I
bought this thing online to use for
camping and it is in worse condition
than I anticipated so I think it's gonna
make an interesting challenge to see
whether I can get this thing usable
again come check this out this thing is
a beast it feels like it weighs about
810 pounds and it is really thick it's
got this removable lid here and you can
see it's got some serious rust damage
down in here you can can see chunks
chunks of it are coming off we've got
large flecks of rust in there luckily
this is really thick so we should have
some room to spare and just not have any
holes in it you can see right here in
the mouth
the rust is so thick now it's built up
in the the mouth of the teakettle the
outside is in a lot better shape than
the inside there's a little bit of
pitting right there a little bit of
pitting right there I take a look at the
bottom and there's no gate mark a gate
mark is like this seam that you see
right across the bottom of cast iron
that's a pre twentieth century and so
this is probably sometime in the 20th
century definitely needs a lot of love
especially on the inside yeah it looks
like it was just sitting with water
inside it or something well we're
starting this teapot isn't going to be
easy but it is gonna be pretty
straightforward I got to remove all the
rust and then I've got a season the cast
iron and removing the rust is gonna be
tricky because there's so many different
little surface areas a little nooks and
crannies that I've got to get to so
hopefully we can do that also by the way
we have some pretty incredible projects
coming up on the outdoor Boise youtube
channel so throughout this video I'm
going to give you some sneak peeks and
let you know what's going on and what
you can expect in the near future we've
got some pretty good stuff coming but
first let's get rid of some rust
[Music]
so this tool I'm using the knock the
rust off is just a third inch diameter
steel rod and I flattened the end out on
my Forge and sharpened it and just put a
little bit of an angle on it I'm using
it like an ice chipper just to get the
sheets of rust off and it seems to be
working really well I am being really
gentle with this hammer and I hear
thunder coming so I think we were able
to take this inside
when we take this little storm break to
show you one of my projects whoo-hoo so
check it out there's one of my projects
it's a hand card that transforms into
like an RV tent type thing
meaning the boys gonna take it on a
multi-day hike still working some of the
bugs out of it and working on that
project that's that's gonna be pretty
exciting so stay tuned that's coming in
the week or two Oh probably shouldn't
leave my my painter out in the rain all
right let me show you some other
projects we're working on I forged and
made about four different fishing Spears
in addition to the ones I already had
and me and the boys are gonna go on a
camping spearing cooking forging you
know video we're gonna be pretty awesome
you know by the time I post this video
online I'm gonna be doing a primitive
survival camping video on a deserted
island with Tommy and Nathan and I'm
pretty excited about that one we're
gonna explore some abandoned facilities
and maybe do some fishing and other
things and it'll be a pretty awesome
adventure but anyway let's get back to
restoring this teakettle hold on Nathan
Nathan what have you been doing baby and
we look anyway about that show me your
tongue oh geez yeah you're hopped up on
sugar boy go ahead and play with your
mama
all right I've knocked off about as much
stuff as I can using this tool so now
I've got this really aggressive abrasion
wheel which is good for smoothing out
pits and things like that knocking off
really stubborn rust and it's much safer
than trying to use the hammer and a
chisel method to get off the stubborn
stuff
well there you can see it's not perfect
but it's a huge improvement check it out
this is all the rust that came out of
the inside of this pea kettle look at
that that's crazy now that I've got most
of the big loose stuff knocked off I'm
gonna go ahead and soak it in a vapor
rust let me show you what I mean this is
a three gallon bucket of a vapor rust
it's a non toxic non acidic
biodegradable chemical that dissolves
rust so if you're gonna be using it on
cookware it's it's probably one of the
best rust remover chemicals I am gonna
take and put my tea kettle in this
pocket here it's a little bit wider fit
and we are gonna cover this thing in a
vapor rust
all right I've had this bucket of a
vapor rust for about a year and a half
two years now and I've used it a lot and
so it's lost a lot of its kick but
hopefully it's got enough oomph left in
it to handle this project it just slowly
turns the rust into like this little
slime that wipes off real easy so we're
gonna let this sit in here for a couple
hours and then we're gonna work on it
and see if we can get more rust off well
it looks like the rain cleared up if you
guys kind of like this sort of thing
check out the link in the description
for my previous cast iron restoration
video where I try and demonstrate three
different methods for removing rust from
cast iron and I kind of show the pros
and cons I'll put a leave the
description so definitely check that out
as well
I'm just waiting for that of April rust
to do its thing and I'm sitting here
realizing I should be doing a child
restoration video well the tea kale has
been in the vaporize for about three
hours now and during that time I decided
that I should destroy my hand cart and
start all over again so I'm doing that
but I think it's time to get back at
that tea kettle here let's pull this tea
kettle out and see what it looks like
here oh it's starting to look pretty
decent oh they got some more more rust
came free that's good yeah that's
looking pretty good
[Music]
looking pretty good a few spots here and
there I need to hit but we're getting
close well the outside is looking pretty
good
but inside there's all these little pits
in there and it's really hard to get all
the rust that's in those little grooves
so I'm gonna try a stronger rust
dissolver and I'm gonna use naval jelly
which is basically a very strong acid
this is toxic stuff so I'm gonna add
just a little bit in here we let it sit
for a few minutes that we're gonna rinse
it out really aggressively all right
it's only been about two minutes and the
naval gel is already getting down to
bare metal so it's about time to wash it
off Tommy over here has kindly filled up
a tub full of water and he's adding some
dish soap to it and of course dish soap
will not only help clean off all the
dirt and everything but it's also a base
so it helps neutralize the acid a little
bit
all right she's looking pretty good
let's try her off
mo what do you think all right let's try
it off and we'll then we'll start
seasoning it all right got the oven
preheated to about four hundred and
sixty degrees we're gonna dry it off in
there all right I've got the teapot
drive in the oven it's nice and hot now
we're gonna coat it in oil to season it
you can use just about any oil or fat to
season cast iron the lung is edible it's
cool I've done flaxseed oil I've done
peanut oil I've done lard it all kind of
works there's lots of different things
you can do and everyone has their
favorite oils I'm gonna go ahead and use
peanut oil because that's what I have
today now I like to season about 450
degrees as most oils smoked at much
lower temperatures than that so there's
gonna be some smokiness there so we're
gonna get to the fan going but basically
you're going to coat it in the oil
let it bake in the oven at about 450 for
about 30-40 minutes and that oil is
gonna get in this hard shell it's gonna
dry out it's gonna polymerize I believe
is the word and it's gonna create that
non-permeable protective nonstick
coating that keeps the rust out now
obviously we're not cooking in a teapot
so we don't need loads of seasoning we
just need enough to keep it from rusting
we're gonna add just probably about two
or three layers of seasoning and that
should be good
normally you turn a cast-iron pot upside
down when you're seasoning but I don't
want a thicker layer of seasoning in the
bottom of the pot so I'm gonna go ahead
and do it right-side up this time well
I'm gonna leave that in there for 40
minutes to start with and I'll take a
peek at it and see how it's doing might
leave it in longer it's kind of a weird
thing to season so we'll play it by ear
you can see because the oil pooled in
the bottom it's still a little bit wet
even after about an hour in the oven so
I'm gonna stick it in for another hour
okay but I'm gonna coat the outside with
the second layer because the outside is
already completely dry looking good
watch me knock this off the rail and
though I have it shatter on the rocks
below okay well we did things a little
differently today I put two coats of
seasoning on but they were really thick
coats and I left it in the oven for two
hours for each layer so a total of four
hours at 450 degrees which is a little
different than how I do it but I really
like the results it's got a lot of
pitting in the bottom and and a lot of
the oil seems to have filled up the
pitting with seasoning so that looks
pretty good I'm gonna let it cool down
and then tomorrow we're going to inspect
it and if it's all good then I'm gonna
go ahead and we're gonna boil some water
over a campfire with that thing all
right now that it's morning and we've
got a little light on our hands let's
check out the teakettle and see if we
like what we see you know on the outside
the seasoning looks so good it's nice
and smooth and not drippy but there's a
few spots here on the inside especially
on the on the wall here where it's a
little spotty and there's one or two
spots like right there and there or I
just for whatever reason the seasoning
didn't quite cover so we're gonna go
ahead and just do at least one other
coating and see if we can get it all
done because
anyplace you don't have seasoning you'll
develop rust so we want to make sure
we're a hundred percent covered with a
protective coating of seasoning when you
apply the oil you want the cast iron to
be hot for a lot of reasons but
unfortunately with this tea kettle I
can't get up inside thoroughly when it's
hot without burning my hand a bunch so
I've put cold oil on cold cast iron cold
oil is thicker and so it applies a
thicker layer of oil this will make more
dripping and more smoking well there we
go perfectly seasoned look at that we've
got so much seasoning down there filling
in the gaps of all those pits the
insides coated I don't see any missed
spots yeah underside is good too even
the handle well this thing wasn't meant
to sit on my shelf we need to go and
build a campfire and boil some water in
this thing let's give it a go I'm gonna
show you how to start a fire using no
matches
[Applause]
[Music]
all right let's check it out
look at that
it's boiling like a champ all right
let's pull it off the fire there we go
it's this handles pretty warm but you
know I can lift that still I'm surprised
that's pretty sure I handled would burn
me mmm hot chocolate well she looks good
she works good it's great to see this
cast-iron cooking again well guys I hope
you enjoyed this video just a quick
little restoration video we got tons of
these types of videos on our channel we
did a whole bunch of axe restoration
bike restoration cast-iron restoration
so I'll put links in the description to
a playlist of all those types of videos
hopefully you guys enjoy this and stay
tuned we've got some pretty amazing
camping videos coming here in the next
few weeks yeah yeah we've got some good
ones so stay tuned and click subscribe
and we'll see you next Saturday if you
like this video don't forget to check
out the outdoor boys youtube channel
where we have hundreds of videos
like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button and you'll get
notifications thanks for watching big if
you like your marshmallow
[Music]